so someone had a question about what is
that growling sound in my stomach
is that just hunger pains what actually
is it you may have these sounds when
you're hungry
but the hunger is not the thing that's
causing it
okay the thing that's causing it is
something called migrating
motor complex now what the heck is that
that is a certain housekeeping
condition in your body where it's
cleaning out the debris
the extra food particles and there's
certain waves of
peristalsis or a pumping action of
debris
going through the small intestine and
into the large
colon why is that so important because
one really important function of this is
to prevent
sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth a lot of people by the way
have this condition they don't even know
it
and that condition is when you have too
much bacteria in your small intestine
the majority should be
in the large intestine when the bacteria
gets into the small intestine
it starts robbing you of nutrients fat
soluble vitamins but like vitamin a
vitamin d potassium vitamin c
zinc and it leaves you deficient not
only that
you start getting fermenting of
vegetables and other fibers that get in
here
and you start experiencing a lot of
bloating so if you consume
like vegetables or fiber or even
probiotics and you feel worse
you could have sibo going on right here
because this mechanism is not working
it's not pushing things
through and when you have sibo you have
a lot of growling going on a lot of
sounds going on there because your body
is trying to clean it out
but it can't okay so let's talk about
what would you do to stop the growling
well it'll stop by eating
but of course if you have sibo you know
if you eat it's gonna you might even
feel more bloating
bile salts are antibacterial
they kill bacteria and usually
people that have sibo are very deficient
in
bile i mean think about it right the
gallbladder is releasing bile into the
small intestine
and the bile goes through the small
intestine and
very little of it ends up in the large
intestine most of it
gets absorbed in the small intestine and
gets recycled
and if you have sibo you're going to
produce
less bile to then kill off the microbes
by taking purified bile salts it'll
greatly help
get rid of sibo also it'll help stop the
growling sounds
and by getting rid of sibo your body
will make more bile
lowering stress will help diminish the
growling sounds
fixing the sibo by taking bile as well
as betaine hydrochloride fixing the
stomach acid as well that will help
both of those last thing and this is
very important is to start doing
intermittent fasting
and give it some time to work because
this mechanism right here kicks in
between 90 minutes and three hours so
if you're eating too frequently you'll
never
give this system a chance to kick in and
do its work
so the more you do intermittent fasting
the more you'll be able to clean this
out and the less growling you're going
to have
because you're going to start to have
more bile to actually make sure that
this bacteria doesn't
stay in there and the fact that eating
stops
this process so you want to go for a
good amount of time
without eating to allow your body to
clean out the debris
by going 16 17 18 hours
of fasting so it can do its house
cleaning if you want some more
information about bile salts i put a
video right here check it out